regarding the situation uh of a traveler
is it forbidden or
optional uh for a traveler to fast Allah
says in the Quran in Surah Bak chapter
number two verse number 185 that if you
are ill or on a journey the prescribed
number of days for fasting can be made
later on so this is a concession given
that means if you want to fast you can
fast if you want to exempt yourself
exemp but later on you have to make up
the period Allah subhana tala here has
compared The Traveler and kept him or
her in the same category as a person who
because the Beloved Prophet M wasallam
said it's mentioned inkari number three
Hadith number 1 804 our beloved Prophet
said that traveling is a punishment or
when a person goes on a journey it's
like a punishment that means it
difficult he has to undergo many
hardships and it is mentioned in say
bukari volume number three book of
fasting Hadith number
1943 there was a Hamza pleas with him
and he used to always fast even on a
journey so he asked the prophet that
should he fast on a journey or not so
the prophet said if you wish to fast you
can fast if you don't to fast you don't
fast that means it was optional if a
person wanted to fast he could fast if
he didn't want he did not fast for
example if a person
who's used to traveling and he does not
find any hardship and if he fast there's
no problem it's good for him or if a
person feels hardship and doesn't want
to fast then he need not fast and this
you come to know from thei of pleas with
him he said it's mentioned in sari
number three Hadith number 1947 where
pleas with him he says then when we used
to travel with the prophet some of the
companions they fasted some of them did
not fast but those who kept the fast did
not criticize those who did not keep the
fast and those who did not fast they did
not criticize those who fasted so
basically it's optional those who can
take the strain and want to fast they
can those who don't want it's up to them
logically from there we we can deduce
that uh it's an optional that's right
fast